what's going on guys national master
james canty the third here with
chess.com and today we have game of the
day
with titled tuesday with the white
pieces we have hikaru nakamura and with
the black pieces we have
liam frolick let's get right into it
nakamura plays knight f3 uh very
flexible something like already
we don't know what he's going to play
yet so let's see what happens d5 and
then here we go
flexibility is very important b3 with
the larson system or
the nimsovich larson attack it's a very
very strong opening and actually very
underrated guys if you don't know what
to do with the black pieces i've had
many positions
where i just didn't know what to do and
i had to study it afterwards so
b3 is very very interesting let's see
what happens here bishop to f5 and then
g3
so he's actually going to finn kettle
both of the bishops here which is
actually very nice
he controls both of the diagonals here
and just has time to do honestly
whatever he wants we're going to sit
back and wait a little bit
e6 and then beautiful move here instead
of bishops of g2 or bishop b2
like we would see in these moves he
actually played knight to h4 stating
that hey you locked your bishop outside
of the pawn chain
bishops are slightly better than knights
all great masters will tell you this
and now with that being said we're going
to capture this bishop
because it's just out here and actually
the bishop pair is always an advantage
and if we're able to take this we're
also able to ruin black's pawn structure
as well
so knight h4 kind of like in a london
system kind of way
with the colors reversed actually
sometimes with black you will see knight
h5 hitting the bishop on f4
trying to take this bishop in london
system fashion so knight h4 then we have
bishop to g4 here trying to provoke a
weakness
and he also just wants to back up this
way maybe take towards the file
h3 bishop to h5 and instead of g4 he
just says bishop b2 let's stay flexible
he didn't he doesn't know what i'm going
to do yet we kind of made some moves he
just threw him off like knight h4 and g3
stuff that he didn't expect right um
right out of the bat here and bishop to
b2 is a good move
knight to d7 doing some development here
and then d3 just uh
get getting some type of uh stake in the
center here e4 is coming followed by uh
of course knight to d2 maybe first and
e4 in a good fashion
especially after we neutralize this
attack right here
so knight g to f6 and then we have g4
there it is on the board guys very
aggressive kind of chess here
very aggressive kind of chess reminds
you of a kings indian but with the
reverse
colors here and you can't castle to the
side of the board guys
you probably should not castle to this
side of the board just because of the
the fact that the pawns are uh loose
here and you push them right in front of
the king and they
supposed to be uh saving your king or
give you some safety and shelter while
your castle bishop to g6 and knight to
d2
then after bishop to d6 we have e3 guys
and if you ever heard of the hippo which
is usually played with the black pieces
you can also play it with white but it
usually goes like this you put your
pawns
only on the third rank it will be the
sixth rank for black but you put your
bishops on
b2 and g2 the knights go to d2 and
usually e2
this one's a little bit far out but you
kind of the same situation where you
actually just kind of sit back and wait
it's more of a counter punching counter
attacking you swing
i duck i swing back i hit kind of thing
it happens all the time a lot of counts
are
counter-attacking chances when you play
this kind of opening but you need to
know
what you're doing do not try this at
home unless you know what you're doing
after e3
queen to e7 and here we go a3 with the
hippopotamus type setup here guys
if you see h3 e3 d3 b3 a3 everything's
on a third rank
besides the g pawn here and the knight's
not on e2 it's on h4 which is a little
bit better here because we can't capture
this bishop here
and uh just kind of a flexible position
just to see what blacks does
e5 and then bishop to g2 by hikaru and
then c6 i'm just going to say hey this
bishop is very strong we don't want it
to be that strong so we're going to make
sure we make this a brick wall in front
of it
queen to e2 i'm not saying where we're
going to castle yet most likely queen
side if we even castle let's see what
happens
castle queen cy and here we go b4 an
aggressive move here
now you guys if you've played if you
played the modern before if you played
the hippopotamus before this is one of
the themes where you actually push this
pawn
bring the knight over and launch a king
or queen side attack
depending on what's going on on the
board here so we may not even see a
castle from icaru let's see what happens
rick hce8
centralizing all of the pieces guys
looks like nothing's wrong here honestly
just a good position kind of can't push
forward yet so we're just trying to
figure out what to do but after rook hd
e8
we have c4 from hikaru he says you know
what i'm not even going to castle
i'm just going to go for it he's going
to attack the king here now when you
cast him on opposite sides whoever gets
to the king first is going to win
but we're actually not even castled here
so we're just going straight for the
king what an all-out attack here
king to b8 just trying to get a little
bit safe here and here comes the
reinforcements
we're bringing our friends for the end
knight b3 and then e4 here
this is a way to break up this strong
center here or what's going on this is
attacked
this is attack if you take this way i
might take this way if you take this way
then i'll take this way so
it's kind of a it's a very strong move
to be honest and actually you have to
respond to it somehow so instead of a d
take c4
here we go knight takes g6 first get rid
of this monster bishop that was on this
diagonal we now have the bishops here
and after knight takes we have h6 h
takes g6
and then c5 attacking the bishop closing
the file and wants to follow up here
guys can you
can you name the next move what would
you do in this position as white if you
were
karu nakamura what would you do why to
move
here we go the move is actually d4 lock
it up
lock it up whoever controls the pawn
breaks controls the game
and in this point who controls the pawn
break what's a pawn break you ask
a pawn break is actually when you can
break up something so
look at this this is a perfect example
f3 is one and b5 is another way
to actually break up this now black
doesn't have any well maybe
b6 but this is not realistic and you
actually don't want to do this with this
king here
more realistically would be maybe f5
here but definitely nothing for black
white controls the game
at the pace that they wanted to and your
pawn structure tells you where you
should play
so realistically black should be playing
on the queen side or king side but it
doesn't look like there's a lot there
and white should be playing on the queen
side where it looks like there's a lot
there so after d4
there's g5 on the board and then we have
a4 he's going forward he's trying to
crush him
let's see if it works knight to f8 then
we have b5
he's opening up the king side and black
is just sitting around
trying to defend and figure out what to
do with life at this point
knight to g6 b takes c6 hey the front
door
is wide open we are going to bring our
friends right inside queen a6 and knight
h4
hitting the bishop here it is attacked
so we do need to do something about it
so
he just backs it up bishop to f1 knight
f3 this knight made how many moves guys
one two
three four moves just to get a check in
we go king d1 and what's your next move
we actually need to use more pieces
remember chess is a team game you can't
just use a knight or any just one piece
to try to win
it does happen sometimes but you are
playing half man half everything else
see caro nakamura
knight f3 it's going to be extremely
hard to get this knight off of here but
you can't you don't have any attack as
black here
it's very very scary here and black is
on the defense queen to d7
trying to defend the light squares
because knight h4 will be one all kind
of things are going to be deadly here
bishop c3 time to open the file even put
a knight maybe on a5 or bishop on a5
king to a8 and then king to c2
interesting move here
maybe activating the rook also keeping
the the knight defended
and even bringing the king just slightly
closer uh okay rook to b8 and then
bishop to e2
he's just trying to develop but also
keep the rooks connected at the same
time
rook to b7 we're gonna double on the
file why not and then rook h to b1 here
it goes
rook e to b8 and here we go guys can you
find
the next move when you look at this kind
of position this position is
placed in front of you what do you do
how do you proceed as white
and the move here guys is bishop b5
whoa and that's not even the best part
of today bishop to b5
this is going to get absolutely crazy at
this point the threat is
of course bishop takes c6 how do you
defend it let's look at the options rook
b6 that's just not a move
and then 95 that's not a move either so
we only have really one option here
which is actually taking
on b5 which he does here c takes b5 here
we go
c6 thank you so much i'm going to win an
exchange here if you do nothing else but
he actually plays rook to b6 and he says
aha
if you take my queen i take yours white
to move guys what do you do in this
position
hikaru nakamura lifted up his mouse and
clicked
queen takes a7 oh my goodness wow
bizarre queen sacrifice tal is here
today
queen takes a seven king takes a takes
b5
rook a6 and rook takes a6
check may have a nice day hikaru
nakamura has done it again here
especially with one of his pet openings
the larson system which you guys can
start playing today
it's an unorthodox opening and people
don't study as much so you do have a big
advantage there that was absolutely
brilliant here
actually right here was the stunning
moment bishop to b5 such a hard move to
find
and then the follow-up here the
follow-up is even the hardest c6
rook b6 and you're like oh what do i do
you look for the forcing moves first
checks and captures queen takes a7
takes takes and check mate have a good
day
wow that was awesome here man what a
game and
what an exciting uh analysis here today
as well guys thank you so much for
watching i'm national master james
canton iii here with chess.com and this
was game of the day and i'll see you
guys
on the next video